on accueille Michel Marie dans un
instant qui va nous dire dans un indice
plus sur cette histoire on a aussi des
audios exclusifs d'un habitant du
village vous faire écouter et c'est vrai
que vous allez voir ce sont des éléments
quand même importants qui nous ont donné
on a joint Gilles par téléphone un
habitant du village qui connaît
parfaitement les lieux et ses habitants
il nous décrit d'abord le village un
tout petit endroit où tout le monde se
connaît forcément écoutez
le village
et le village est composé de plusieurs
mots et ce fameux hameau du haut Vernet
qui est à 2 km du du village quoi et qui
est un endroit où là tout était trois
pour y accéder quand on arrive en haut
il y a qu'une piste forestière pour
s'éclaper donc il faut avoir une voiture
très haute
pour faire demi-tour il y a un jardin au
milieu quoi il faut faire deux trois
manœuvres comme pour moi c'est quasiment
impossible d'aller là-haut et de faire
demi-tour sans que personne voit la
voiture
alors ces Gilles d'habitants du village
vous allez voir ce qui nous vient dans
un instant vous allez voir toutes les
hypothèses sont complètement folles de
cette histoire si vous n'avez pas suivi
cette affaire il est 20h57 et c'est vrai
que cette histoire est complètement
folle Michel que s'est-il passé c'était
il y a deux mois
c'était le samedi 8 juillet
Émile deux ans et demi est arrivé chez
ses grands-parents
grands-parents qui ont cette belle
maison au Verney Provence comment on les
a tous
une maison familiale ce jour-là il y
avait 6 donc les tentes qui étaient
présents Émile était arrivé la veille
dans la main Didier dans la matinée il
avait joué avec ses petits cousins ils
avaient construit un une cabane en bois
une centaine de mètres de ce de cette
maison et il était fasciné par cette
cabane en bois il à l'heure du déjeuner
il voulait pas rentrer à la maison parce
qu'il voulait rester dans la cabane bref
on l'a un peu obligé à rentrer il a fait
sa sieste vers 15h il s'est réveillé il
voulait retourner dans la cabane sauf
que le grand-père Philippe avait décidé
autre chose et c'est une famille très
unie ils font tous ensemble
quand ils font une randonnée tout le
monde le monde participe à la randonnée
quand ils vont à la piscine tout le
monde va à la piscine bref il c'est
comme ça que ça fonctionne chez eux donc
il n'était pas question que le petit
Emile aille à la cabane et le temps
qu'il s'organise je crois que cet
après-midi là il avait prévu de faire
une clôture pour les chevaux et donc
tout le monde devait
participer à cette clôture et
à un moment donné je crois vers 17h il
s'aperçoit vos membres partir il
s'aperçoivent Kevin n'est pas là
le grand-père sort c'est un tout petit
village il y a 17 maisons donc c'est et
en plus c'est un cul-de-sac c'est à dire
que c'est vraiment on est on est en vase
clos le grand-père sort croise deux
témoins qui ont vu Émile quelques
minutes plus tôt
enfin quelques minutes plus tôt on n'a
pas on n'a pas le créneau horaire exact
le problème c'est que c'est deux témoins
il y en a un qui a 16 ans l'autre qui
est retraité ils disent pas la même
chose en termes de direction qu'aurait
emprunté l'enfant le retraité dit qui
descendait et le jeune de 16 ans dit
qu'il montait
bref on ne retrouve pas Émile et à 18h
le grand-père donne l'alerte appelle la
gendarmerie et très vite des gros
effectifs viennent sur place je crois
qu'il y a 90 gemmes plus les bénévoles
plus les brigades cynophiles et on fera
décoller ensuite un hélicoptère avec un
radar qui permet d'un radar thermique
qui permet
de de retrouver éventuellement une trace
de ses enfants alors depuis le début de
cette affaire vous allez voir les
révélations on va vous faire dans un
instant et ce que dit le l'habitant du
village ce qui a surpris beaucoup de
personnes c'est qu'un petit garçon de 2
ans se balade seul dans la rue Gilles
pour lui il n'y a rien d'étonnant à cela
écoutez
les gens ne comprennent pas quelque
chose c'est que les enfants sont libres
alors oui c'est un petit de deux ans et
demi le hameau du haut vernis on va dire
c'est une grande famille quoi moi il
pourrait tout seul faire du vélo dans la
villa
donc voilà donc c'est plutôt voilà c'est
c'est ça arrive dans le village de ce
qu'ils disent Michel alors il y a plein
de théories qui sont arrivés sur cette
affaire qui sont complètement folles ce
que vous pouvez nous donner alors en
fait c'est samedi 10 juillet de le 8
juillet ça marque le début de cette
triste histoire il y a un avis de
recherche qui diffusait on va sous le
dimanche et le 10 juillet il y a la
maman des milles qui publie un poste
Facebook veuillez prier la vénérable
soeur Benoîte encurel mystique des
apparitions du los le diable l'emmenait
régulièrement dans la montagne pour la
persécuter et les anges la ramenés la
maman des mines
les différentes pistes exploitées parce
que il y en a plusieurs il y a plusieurs
théories déjà depuis la faire le visage
et divin le village est évidemment sous
choc il règne un vrai climat de méfiance
par excès la folie tout le monde se
regarde tout le monde se dit qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé il y a une omerta totale
regardez écoutez
aujourd'hui on est en malaise de
suspicion quoi et les gens sont
regardent les uns les autres il y en a
un qui conduit un peu vite dans le
village ou qui s'est arrêté de boire de
pastilles souvent ou l'autre qui a fait
une vidéo il sort un peu du commun alors
on dit celui-là il est pas tranquille
donc
ça pension quoi alors il y a différentes
pistes ce que vous pouvez nous donner
parce qu'il y a des pistes complètement
incroyables il y a la piste de la fugue
mais qui a été a priori assez rapidement
abandonné parce qu'il y a un enfant de 2
ans et demi il va pas parcourir 10 km à
pied il y avait une carte bleue
oui ça ça m'arrangerait ah oui
quand je dis flux c'est l'enfant qui
sort de chez ses grands-parents et qui
se perdent bien sûr ça c'est pas
possible évidemment il a pas tout le
monde sait tous dit de toute façon un
enfant de 2 ans il peut pas aller bien
loin c'est ce que c'est la règle on a
tous en fait c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
qu'on s'est posé la question de savoir
si c'était utile de ratisser 96 hectares
ce qui a été fait bon c'est fait c'est
fait parce que ce que disent les
enquêteurs quand même et qui est un
point hyper important on a un peu avancé
dans l'enquête c'est que comme il y a eu
ce ce s'est battu qui ont été organisés
ils disent que s'il devait rester
malheureusement
des traces de de corps ou quelque chose
qui qui peut ou des effets personnels on
le saurait déjà la même chose dans la
faire Lucas et
bah en tous les cas ce que j'ai compris
de la faire c'est que cette hypothèse là
elle est un peu laissée de côté pour le
moment et que et que il travaille en
vaselot maintenant avec une enquête à la
Agatha Christie parce que ils savent un
petit peu quelles sont les protagonistes
du village et que pour les enquêteurs
tout tourne autour des personnes qui
sont là il y a une intervention humaine
à un moment alors s'il vous plaît ils
ont mobilisé des chiens et les chiens
s'arrêtent au niveau du lavoir à chaque
fois pourquoi parce que c'est sans doute
la dernière endroit où cet enfant
s'est arrêté ce qu'il est ce qu'un
quelqu'un l'a pris dans ses bras et la
ramener à la maison a priori c'est pas
le cas est-ce qu'il a été enlevé et ce
qui est monté dans une voiture il faut
dire aussi quand même qu'il régnait une
une pagaille monstrueuse dans ce village
au tout début dès qu'on a appris la
disparition de cet enfant les pompiers
sont venus avec leur chien les les
bénévoles ont prêté main fortes donc on
piétinait tout le village et donc je
pense que que aussi que les les
tracesolfactives ont pu parce que une
trace olfactive elle est on peut pas
l'adapter ça peut être la veille l'odeur
de cet enfant il était passé au lavoir
la veille
alors il y a trois théories qui
reviennent le plus dans le village
Gilles nous en a parlé le habitant du
village on a interrogé il dénonce les
accusations qui sont parfois gratuites
écoutées
[Musique]
et noter que je ne peux pas imaginer
de soi-disant un gosse de sésame qui
conduit une tracteur à vivre à Lyon
alors
déjà que il manque des points alors ça
ce sont des criminels et il se
permettent de critiquer un jeune qui a
16 ans et qui conduit l'autre acteur un
peu plus vite voilà ça et puis après par
la
science est un accident voilà je sais
pas pourquoi ils auraient caché ça après
on a parlé aussi je sais pas il y en a
un dans le RD qui fait des vidéos alors
il y a des gens qui s'amusent à dire que
c'était des équilibré et puis si il a
envie de faire des vidéos moi aussi je
fais des vidéos ça va pas que je suis
déséquilibré quoi il y a certaines
personnes qui laissent planer des
suspicions pour des vengeances
personnelles
de profiter de ce drame
pour régler des comptes personnelles il
va revenir sur une dernière théorie qui
fait énormément parler là dernièrement
Gilles dans un instant vous allez voir
mais Gilles Verdez c'est quoi les trois
théories pour noter les spectateurs
parce que tout le monde a parlé de cette
histoire ça fait flipper tout le monde
on se dit voilà un enfant de 2 ans qui
disparaît jour au lendemain depuis deux
mois on n'a pas de nouvelles pas de
traces on sait pas ce qu'il est devenu
c'est fou alors c'est quoi les trois
théories alors d'abord il y a la théorie
fantaisie qui a été balayée mais quand
même expertisé celle d'un rapace il
aurait été enlevé alors justement donc
ça c'est la dernière théorie dont on va
parler dans un instant voilà c'est la
dernière l'autre théorie c'est la
vengeance familiale il faut avoir que
les grands-parents avaient vu une de
leurs maisons brûlée en 2019 ils avaient
acheté un hameau trois maisons brûlées
dont une des grands-parents est-ce que
ce serait la poursuite de cette
vengeance c'est un incendie qui est
criminel mais qui n'a pas été qui n'a
pas donné lieu à interpellation ni à
jugement donc est-ce que elle est aussi
est-ce que quelqu'un en veut à cette
famille voilà et l'autre théorie
plausible c'est la théorie entre
guillemets accidentelle intra-familial
c'est-à-dire qui s'est passé quelque
chose et d'ailleurs c'est ce que les de
déterminer ils auditionnent au moins
trois heures chaque protagoniste qui
était au Vernet à l'époque pour mailler
totalement l'emploi du temps de chacun
est-ce que quelqu'un a fait quelque
chose à l'enfant et ensuite
éventuellement à cacher le corps voilà
alors c'est ça aujourd'hui
on en est où parce que c'est vrai qu'on
entend beaucoup de choses sur cette
affaire aujourd'hui on en est où et on
va revenir sur la dernière théorie vous
parliez dans l'instant malheureusement
on en est on n'a pas beaucoup évolué
enfin l'enquête a pas beaucoup évolué à
ma connaissance en même temps les
gendarmes gardent leur investigations
très secrètes ils communiquent
absolument plus sur ce point maintenant
sur le sur l'histoire de la de la
vengeance à Moïse qui tient pas c'est
que pour kidnapper un enfant faut être
sûr de pouvoir avoir accès à l'enfant
enfin pouvoir l'enlever là il y a les
oncles les temples grand-père c'est un
tout petit village où il y a peu de
monde qui circulent donc c'est compliqué
l'enlèvement ça me paraît finalement
Gilles l'habitant du village nous
explique pourquoi il peut pas croire ire
à la théorie de l'enlèvement du petit
garçon écoutez
c'est une route qui est classée
départementale elle est toute petite on
a du mal à se croiser pour que quelqu'un
enlève le petit à 17h15 c'est quand même
improbable d'être là au moment où il
serait sa sortie
et en plus il aurait fallu pour que la
voiture reparte après il aurait fallu
que le fasse demi-tour sur le hameau et
pour faire demi-tour sur leur amour
gloirement il aurait fallu qu'elle fasse
deux trois manœuvres donc quand il y a
10 maisons d'habiter on entend une
voiture qui manœuvre ce qui se passe
enlève la tête on
voit la coupe en voiture je la connais
je la connais pas mais or aujourd'hui
donc pour moi c'est quel probable cette
solution alors ce qui est inquiétant
c'est que le 25 juillet soit 17 jours
après la disparition du petit Émile qui
reste introuvable les enquêteurs de
l'Institut de Recherche criminel de la
gendarmerie nationale a été toujours
présent vernis et des chiens
particuliers sont arrivés au vernis des
chiens qui ne sont pas utilisés lorsque
l'on pense encore trouver la personne
vivante c'est c'est pas bon signe c'est
de toute façon je pense qu'il faut pas
se faire trop d'illusions depuis deux
mois envie d'avoir espoir encore on peut
avoir envie d'avoir espoir mais si on
n'est pas pragmatique cet enfant de 2
ans et demi sauf s'il a été enlevé par
quelqu'un en mal d'enfant ça peut
arriver mais pour les raisons qu'on
expliquait tout à l'heure ça paraît
compliqué
je crois qu'un médecin disait que le
l'espoir de survie faisait 30 degrés le
8 juillet un enfant de cet âge-là s'il
est pas hydraté en 48 heures il est il
est mort là ça fait deux mois après bon
je veux bien qu'on garde l'espoir mais
ça me paraît quand même une une
hypothèse peut
justement les parents les parents ils
ont pris la parole le 29 août 2023 ils
ont répondu aux questions d'un
journaliste du média famille chrétienne
ils ont dans un premier temps tenu à
remercier toutes les personnes qui sont
mobilisées pour tenter de retrouver leur
fils ils sont également revenus sur
différentes accusations déclarants nous
n'avons pas honte d'aimer la messe
traditionnelle à laquelle nous assistons
de notre diocèse nous y animons
d'ailleurs en famille la chorale
polyphonique et grégorienne nous
militons au centre Charlier et à la
griffe et nous en sommes fiers nous
n'avons absolument rien à cacher parce
qu'on les avait attaqué là-dessus
à partir du moment où les gens en mode
de vie un petit peu différent des autres
forcément quand il arrive un drame dans
la famille on va chercher le petit
détail mais c'est en tout cas pas un
argument d'enquête qui soit catholique
pratiquant qui soit catholique
intégriste ils sont défendent ils sont
très très religieux après Harry mais il
se défendent de faire partie d'une secte
religieuse informations particulières au
sujet de leur fils l'enquête continue
dans le secret de l'instruction ne faut
pas lui dire de notre côté nous
continuer à faire confiance au travail
des gendarmes on imagine forcément le
pire mais on ne peut s'empêcher
d'espérer nous ne tournons pas la page
nous continuons à espérer nous demandons
à tous ceux qui veulent faire quelque
chose pour nous de continuer à prier et
il y a une autre piste donc une théorie
aussi celle des rapaces et des loups
écoutez l'habitant du village revient
là-dessus
mais la caca ça reste là
oui pas de vêtements rien donc c'est
aussi une hypothèse farfelue
alors je vais aller dessus farfelue
par rapport au poids de l'enfant et puis
il a quand même dans ce village
quelqu'un aurait vu quelque chose un
aigle qui part avec un enfant de 2 ans
et demi dans le dans ses griffes on se
quand même que ce serait pas passé
inaperçu donc il y a la théorie
effectivement de qu'évoquait Gilles
Verdez qui semble
intéressé fortement les enquêteurs c'est
peut-être un niveau intra familial
mais languettes une fois de plus
c'est assez rare d'ailleurs on a un
procureur qui le dénon juillet disait
qu'il n'avait aucune piste aucun élément
aucun indice qu'il avait rien de cette
histoire
mais aucune piste disait le procureur
d'ailleurs il ne fait pas et par
ailleurs la famille
s'est portée aussi vite pour avoir accès
au dossier
alors directement
elle aura pas accès au dossier tant
qu'il y aura pas quelqu'un de mis en
examen donc
alors tout le monde s'intéresse à la
famille du petit Émile qui fait face à
de nombreuses rumeurs sur leur profil
regarde
cette famille catholique traditionaliste
aurait-elle pu être victime d'une
vengeance d'un règlement de compte en
raison de son engagement à
l'ultra-droite les parents d'Émile
colombants et Marie ont fait partie du
bastion social
un mouvement néo-fasciste fondé par des
anciens membres de l'Action française
on les voit ici sur cette photo entouré
de leur camarades
le père des milles qui est alors
étudiant ingénieur comparait en 2018
devant le tribunal correctionnel
d'Aix-en-Provence pour avoir molesté un
couple d'origine maghrébine l'un de ses
amis sera condamné lui relaxé le bastion
social est finalement dissout par
Emmanuel Macron en 2019
alors oui après pourquoi ça intéresse
les enquêteurs c'est pas tant leur
profil en tant que tel qu'ils soient
catholique très à droite rigoriste ok
mais c'est est-ce que cela aurait pu
susciter une vengeance est-ce que est-ce
que voilà des gens pourraient les haïr
politiquement d'avoir été dans cette
organisation à ce moment-là c'est pour
ça que les enquêteurs ont travaillé
travaillent encore sur cette piste aussi
même s'il s'en éloigne aujourd'hui oui
là dans ce dans cette configuration ils
auraient pas enlevé l'enfant ils
auraient tué l'enfant ils auraient
laissé le l'enfant pour montrer que
c'était une vengeance alors c'est quoi
alors aujourd'hui vous qui connaissez
quand même ces affaires qui avait eu
accès quand même à l'enquête vous dites
quoi
on n'en sait rien on a deux ans et demi
qui a disparu du jour au lendemain dans
un petit village de combien d'habitants
salut sinon 125 125 habitants et dans le
hameau en haut 15
parce que
125 mais en haut c'est 15 habitants
volatilisés c'est à dire qu'en 5 minutes
on a plus de traces de cet enfant même
moins de 5 minutes il y a pas il faut le
dire au téléspectateurs il n'y a pas un
témoin
le témoin ils ont vu Émile il y a un
traité il y a un traité qui le voit
pendant une direction et un jeune
adolescent de 16 ans qu'il voit prendre
une autre direction il est tout seul
il allait pour un des deux témoins il
allait vers cette fameuse cabane qu'on a
évoqué cette cabane elle intéresse
beaucoup les enquêteurs parce qu'elles
passionnait Émile alors il voulait aller
vers cette cabane à ce moment-là selon
un des deux témoins il avait fabriqué
avec son grand-père voilà toutes
l'équation c'est est-ce qu'il a été
là-bas est-ce qu'il désobéit est-ce
qu'on la retrouvait là-bas est-ce que
cette cabane est un lieu névralgique
pour les enquêteurs il se pourrait bien
que autour de cette cabane ce sont
potentiellement passer quelque chose
c'est une des pistes est-ce qu'on a puni
c'est une des pistes et alors on pense
bien sûr pour les parents ça doit être
terrible terrible terrible c'est
vraiment c'est ici moi j'ai du mal à
croire que personne ne sache rien dans
le village c'est ce qui est un village
de 15 ou 30 habitants
un cul-de-sac où on s'est forcément qui
va dans un sens qui va dans l'autre je
je comprends enfin j'arrive pas à
comprendre
ne saurai rien je pense que il y a des
gens vous disiez la piste de la
disparition elle est écartée d'abord
d'un point de vue du chef d'incubation
l'enquête elle est ouverte aussi pour
pour enlèvement et séquestration alors
c'est aussi pour des raisons techniques
parce que ça permet aux magistrats de
d'élargir les enquêtes mais c'est pas
impossible non plus quoi enfin du tout
est possible merci à vous merci à vous
d'avoir été avec nous